you know I am so excited to check out  some of the big movies being previewed  at Comic Con this year which movie are  you most excited about Andy Andy what do  you want Andy what the hell happened to  you just a little hungry I'm gonna call  for a nurse  I think Andy you need a Snickers bar  [Music]  and he just just grab one from that  perfectly manicured display next to your  lectern there you go just take one right  off the top isn't that nice  yeah rip it off and take a big bite I'm  really really sorry about this everyone  Andy is just not himself when he's  hungry you feeling better now Andy now  thanks Donen and thank you Snickers yeah  he ate my only friend okay that's the  strangest ending anything